CRISES IN THE WORLD TODAY,
ISIS WAGES
S YEAR BUTGE AND CHINAIN FAL AGT
C ACTIVISTS,
NOTER MUR OWND CHINA
REMAIN ADDD  COAL.ELLER FOUNDATN
AIM$100 MILLION AN
OWER
BILLPEOPLE AND A SENDING
400 TONSGREENH
I SMOK R, D HE ITHPR
FORMER HFOY
FOR INATL DEVELOPMENT.
>> THA FAREED.
FIRSET ME PUT THIS IN
PEISE FOUNDATION I GREENUNOUE D.
T SF THAT
AND THIS IS PEA
CHNGYOU , TODAINRDTOATE CHANGE,
TS OBY THNCODEOPLIS PLANET ONL
YEAR OND ELECTRICITYTH'S/1T
L COE.
THE
ENER OVER TITION IS,IT GOING ORR
PLND HELP THE
IMRTT FAMILIES AND IES LIFT TEL
TING FOR
ER>> TELL US, WITHREEN
REVOON W AIS
NEW TECHNOLOGY THAT WAS USED.WH
YOU CAN TH
ELECTRICITY SO THAT MANY PEOPLE?
>>HEWE
WE DECADE
AS ROCRI
THIS R-INCOM
COMMUNIEOLARIDS, WE'VE SE COST I
ENERGY STORAGE DOWN MOHAN
E HU
INITONHATE
BAFOR STATNA SMAL AND MICROGRID.
IT'S NOW CHEAPER TO PROVIDE
WE WAY
RT G
CD  THA
TRY TO RNTO THESPOORLY.
>> IN THATASE, WHYS RKET NOT DOT
U
T PROVIDING R ARTICULAR AS TRADM
D BIG COAL T GRIDEXTR
COD NNT ES,  TO SMA OS
EXPENSIVE.
AND STTH TVER  ERRATIC AND THE
T VERY G
G THAT.ESE NELOADED
WITHOLY.
DDN TO PHOOERJ, THEYSEFILIGENCBA
A R HOUSAY FOR ANDPHONE ANVERYS
PRODUCVE F, FARE
WO, WE PARTNERPOR,CH I
ROLLING OUT  OF STEMS IN.T THE R
15 CENT AN
BSO5 MILLIOLE NOT JUST
MOVE OUT OBUON
N DEVELOENS  FOR OUR
>> WHEN WILL WE SEE REALNG IS IE
SMALE.
WHEN WILL WEEEMILLIONS AND MILL
GRIDSIG WLD WE
MIN STOMERS,0,000 IN ALO
IS NOT JUST THAT TEIBILLS ANIT W
LADDER.E THE
IGELSEWINGNDTASS
AGPRODUCER WHO THEUSES A RICIN
FAECONOMICOWN BUNET THEI
THAT TREND IS  ALL , AND WE BEL
AT THEINA DECADE
ENEW